transgender decision a divisive issue
how difficult a decision was it
well it was a decision that was based on
important and fundamental principle and
that is that as an International
Federation
that has a vibrant female element in our
sport that it was absolutely vital that
we protected the female category and
we've done this afternoon what we felt
what we feel is in the best interest of
our sport we're not leaving it at that
because we are setting up a working
group The working group will contain
transgender athletes and we want to
understand more about the science the
science on transgender is not as robust
we absolutely accept as it is on DSD
which was the other issue that we had to
deal with today but the reality of it is
at this moment we don't have any
transgender athletes in Elite
competition and the consultation was
very very clear
across all our major stakeholders they
did not feel at this point that we
should have transgender athletes
competing at Elite level and that is the
decision the council took and this has
been a long lengthy process and it's
been a good process it's been important
that we listen to people who are out in
the field coaches athletes member
federations uh and a number of other
communities and this is the Judgment
that we made today and I think it is the
right judgment so you clearly felt that
the female categories in Elite Sport
would have been compromised is is that
what you is that what the decision is
based on
yes absolutely and our responsibility is
clear there's there's no ambiguity about
it I'm elected to
do what we think is in the always in the
best interest of the sport and we felt
that having transgender athletes
competing at Elite level uh was would
actually compromise the Integrity of
female female competition
now you're on record as saying if it
comes down to a judgment between
inclusion and fairness you will always
come down on the side of fairness
fairness you said is non-negotiable I
just wonder what you would say to a
transgender athlete who says that this
is unfair
well first of all we don't have any uh
transgender athletes in international
competition that day may come but until
we understand a great deal more about
the science around this which we don't
as I've said we have 15 years
of uh information and data on the
approach that we've taken also this
afternoon to our DSD athletes we don't
have that so we have to fall back on a
very fundamental principle and that is
that we are here charged with the
responsibility of defending the female
category and that is what we've done
um do you fear lawsuits as a result of
this do you fear some Court action
so the decisions that we made today
um around DSD about transgender also uh
the decision that the council took on
the continued exclusion of Russian and
Bella Russian athletes uh from our world
championships is not you know it's not a
challenge-free Zone there are legal
challenges there are medical challenges
there are certainly communication
challenges uh I'm rather of the view
that we we tackle those head-on in the
way that we did when we suspended the
Russian Federation for the egregious
attack on the Integrity of our sport
through state-sponsored anti-doping uh
doping so look you know it's it's not
the path we would choose but if you feel
you've done the right thing you must
then be in a position to defend it and
we will vigorously defend the positions
that we've taken today there were
reports that you may decide to reduce
the blood testerone levels the from five
nanomoles per liter to 2.5
why did you decide to do what you have
decided
regulations we have moved to two points
uh over over the two years
um the reason for the separation from
our uh from our DSD regulator or the
separation of the DSD regulations and
the transgender regulations is is really
what I alluded to in our opening
exchanges that we have a great deal more
science and data and information
available to us over the 15 years that
we have been dealing on the front line
with DSD athletes nobody has that kind
of data and we don't have the front line
analysis that we can use from the field
of play Because as I've said we don't
actually have any transgender athletes
competing at International level we
don't know enough we need to know more
and that's why the working group will
now start looking at these issues so
we're not saying this is this is written
in tablets of stone but for the
foreseeable future we need to understand
a great deal more about the science and
then maybe we look at this again but
that will be probably for count Souls
you know and and my successes and I know
that other sports uh swimming for
instance have taken similar decisions do
you think that
most if not all Olympic sports will end
up at the same position
Mark I don't know
um they may well uh we didn't Benchmark
the decision we took today on anything
other than the the the the the work that
we've done in our own Sport and
certainly throughout the consultation so
if if other sports choose to do that I'm
sure they will have made the same
judgment that it is in the best
interests of their sport uh we we did
exactly that today I think it is the
right judgment uh and it's it was pretty
clear-cut uh from the consultation that
we've been that's been underway for many
months and just finally said on the
Russian athletes um am I right is saying
you've lifted the doping ban but they
are still banned because of the war the
band because of the war in Ukraine
um how can you be satisfied that Russian
States you know doping has stopped
because we've had a task force a working
task force that's been dealing with this
for seven years this is our eighth year
uh we agreed a reinstatement program
with uh the Russian Athletics Federation
uh seven years ago now 2015 2016
um and it was to the best assessment of
our uh working group independently
chaired by one of the world's leading
experts in this space and the imposition
in the Russian Federation of our of
independent advisors that will remain in
that Federation for the next two or
three years with some special
requirements uh yeah they we on the
strictest interpretation of that road
map after seven years we felt that they
had done what we asked them to do and
effectively we are now in control of
those athletes and the testing through
the athletic intake Equity unit that we
created in the reforms the issue around
Belarus and Russia was to continue the
exclusion of those athletes because of
the current situation and Mark you know
185 athletes in Ukraine have lost their
lives I sat not that long ago with an
athlete who lost her mother in a missile
attack I'm afraid I couldn't remain
neutral on that uh not for her and not
for the other 185 athletes these are
never easy decisions yes they always in
one way or another can set precedence
but I'd rather deal with those as and
when they come there isn't there's not
the threshold of morality here right if
the Ukraine war is continuing uh during
the Paris Olympics no Russian or
belarussian athletes at those Olympics
that is what our sport has said today
and the one thing that is very clear is
that the Primacy for the selection of
athletes the eligibility of those
athletes for National Olympic committees
around the world to select has to reside
with the International Federation we've
upheld that Primacy today and so as far
as the council is concerned there won't
be uh Russian or better Russian athletes
in Paris